seat pale blood to transcend bunt every
Souls game begins with a goal slay the
arch demons ring the bell of awakening
seek the king and yet in all of those
stories those goals were not the end
they didn't hold the answers we were
looking for but they did set us on the
right path and it was on the path to
these goals that we found our answers
blood-borne is no different so we seek
the pale blood pale what do you say hmm
never heard of it but if it's blood
you're interested in you should try the
healing church the church controls all
knowledge on blood ministration and all
varieties of blood blood ministration is
the art of using blood for healing in a
time before the events of the game the
healing church became immensely powerful
due to the healing qualities of their
special healing blood somehow they had
created or found a blend that could cure
any illness and so as you would expect
travelers from far and wide joining to
Yanam seeking this special blood to cure
their illnesses
Gilbert is one of these travelers he
mentions that what ailed him was
incurable but that the special blood
bought him time we ourselves were
administered with yarn and blood in the
opening cutscene and many sources say
that we had an incurable disease as well
blood became the focus of worship and
desire and the church was at the center
of it all the pungent blood cocktail
item states that in yharnam they
produced more blood than alcohol as the
former is more intoxicating and all was
likely well for a time for the church
had time to grow more powerful and the
yharnam blood had time to gather a
reputation but then it became clear that
the blood was tainted the art book
states that the healing blood gave rise
to the endemic nightmare known as the
scourge of the Beast and the men who had
imbibed the blood began to turn arms
lengthened hair grew blood thirst rose
and when we arrived in yharnam we find
that there are very few humans left
coffins lie in the streets
it's clear that death had become a new
part of the daily routine frantically
the church rallied together a force to
fight the beast outbreak by inspection
of the Arnhem Hunter cap we learn of the
cleric Ludwig the first hunter of the
healing church Ludwig recruited the men
of yharnam to serve as hunters this
hunters attire was made for new recruits
but it was not nearly enough to allow
ordinary men to stand any real chance
against the beasts and yet
Ludwig's influence is seen throughout he
Arnhem in the hunt that is carried out
by the men of the town each night with
steel and fire the men of yharnam fought
the beasts since the tragedy that struck
all the Arnhem Fire has become a staple
in the Beast hunts and is thought to
cleanse impurity certain types of beasts
also have an abnormal fear of flame the
Molotov cocktail is one of the oldest
hunter tools in the workshop sometimes
when hunters burn beasts they appear
intoxicated by the euphoria of
purification despite all these hunts
Ludwig's attempts to rally the men of
yharnam backfired in a way those who
engaged in the Beast hunt became
overwhelmed with fear and bloodlust and
their transformation into a beast was
ironically fast-forwarded different men
turn into different beasts and most men
of yharnam are half turned patrolling
the streets in a hunt that may never end
the same Jana mites hide indoors and as
you've probably experienced they spurn
the outsider stupid enough to be caught
outside on the night of the hunt we
fight our way through the moonlit
streets trying to find this valley to
the east of yharnam and the great bridge
that will lead us to the cathedral ward
normally they wouldn't let you near the
place but the hunt is on tonight this
might be your chance Ludwig was the
first of many healing Church hunters to
come many of whom were clerics as it was
clerics turned into the most hideous
beasts the cleric beast leaps from the
cathedral ward and we fight what became
of the first church hunter Ludwig take
from this encounter that to be close to
the church is to transform into a more
complex Beast
perhaps the more insight you have into
the
churches doings the more complicated
your transformation it's something worth
keeping in mind as we continue to
explore because this theme continues
after the cleric beast is defeated one
can obtain the hunter chief emblem an
item that belonged to the captain of the
church hunters long ago it opens one of
the main church gates in the church
courtyard which would close behind
Ludwig every time he embarked on yharnam
to engage in the hunt it would then open
upon presentation of the hunter chief
emblem but that gate has been closed
ever since for Ludwig became the cleric
beast and even though Ludwig gave his
own humanity to lead the hunt the
villagers saw only the churches
abandonment this note II find
reads when the hunt began the healing
church abandoned us
blocking the great bridge to the
cathedral ward as they burned all the
Arnim to the ground that moonlit night
when we go across it the great bridge is
of course still blocked so we have to
find a different way to the cathedral
ward on our path through the sewers we
meet Aileen a veteran hunter who tells
us that tonight is one of the worst
hunts she's ever seen prepare yourself
for the worst there are no humans left
there are flesh hungry beasts now you'll
notice that she stands beside an incense
lantern the incense spreads a scent that
repels beasts they're commonly found
outside of the homes of the same
experience dianna mites wherever you see
a lantern there is safety from the
beasts and the people who hide inside
are safe as long as they have a store of
this incense we come across another
Lantern later which protects a little
girl from the horrors outside and you
hand her his food look for my mom she
never came back from the home and she
went to find him but now he's gone too
her father is a man named Gascoigne who
went on a hunt and never returned
we find him here at the end of the
sewers in the tumor Verdun harvesting
the blood of beasts Gascoigne is the
perfect example of a man gone mad from
the hunt he's forgotten his child he's
killed his wife and we also have to
remember that those of the church turned
into the most hideous beasts hunter
attire worn by father Gascoigne the
dingy scarf was once a holy shawl and a
symbol of the healing church from which
Gascoigne would eventually part ways
father is a title used for clerics in a
foreign land but there is no such rank
in the healing Church Gascoigne's attire
is similar to the hunter garb that was
created the workshop only it's tainted
by a pungent beastly stench that eats
away at him so why did Gascoigne leave
the church was it to raise this family
that he had at home or was it because he
found he disagreed with the new Church's
teachings there is much more to the
healing Church than there seems you're
sure to be in a fine haze about now but
don't think too hard about all of this
just go out and kill a few beasts it's
for your own good you know it's just
what hunters do
you